FANATICS IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
THE PRESIDENT'S VISIT TO DAVOS
HE ENGAGED WORLD LEADERS ON THE
SIDELINES AND HE DELIVERED A
SPEECH THAT WAS DISCIPLINED,
SERIOUS AND UNAPOLOGETIC.
OTHER COUNTRIES SHOULD PUT THEIR
COUNTRY FIRST ALSO.
BUT AMERICA FIRST DOES NOT MEAN
AMERICA ALONE.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT
DELIVERED A CALMED AND
SHOWING RESPECT TO OUR
INTERNATIONAL ALLIES.
DESPITE HOW WELL THE PRESIDENT
IT'S PATHETIC.
HERE'S WHAT SOME OF THEM THOUGHT
OF THE DAVOS SPEECH.
>> IT'S LIKE A TONE TO THE MORE
MEASURED -- I GUESS, WHAT'S THE
WORD, SEDATED.
I WAS STRUCK BY THE LACK OF
ENERGY.
>> Laura: WELL, HAD THE
PRESIDENT BEEN REALLY ANIMATED,
THEY WOULD HAVE SAID, HE'S
YELLING, HE'S SHOUTING, HE LOOKS
ANGRY.
THE UGLY AMERICAN.
HE SOUNDS LIKE OLD DUCCE.
AND REMEMBER, EVEN BEFORE
INAUGURATION DAY, THEY INSISTED
HIS ARROGANT TONE AND POPULIST
POLICIES WOULD DESTROY HIM AND
THE PLANET.
AND THEY PORTRAY HIM 24/7 AS A
DICTATOR IN WAITING AND A FAN --
FANATIC WHO DEMANDS LOYALTY AND
NOW WE SEE THE TRUE FANATICS.
THE MEDIA.
THE BREAKING NEWS AND MILITARY
DICTATE
DICTAT
DICTATORSHIP.
>> THE IMPULSES OF A TYRANT AND
DICTATOR.
>> HE ATTACKS THE NEWS
INSTITUTIONS WHICH IS WHAT
FRANCO AND MUSSOLINI AND OTHERS
DID.
>> THE KIND OF STRATEGY --
DICTATORS AND TYRANTS HAVE USED.
>> HE'S ATTACKING THE PRESS
HE CALLS THEM THE ENEMY PEOPLE
WHICH IS RHETORIC YOU HEAR FROM
STALLIN.
>> Laura: KILLED 50 MILLION
PEOPLE BUT IT'S THE SAME AS
TRUMP.
OH, MY GOSH.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SLAVISH
ADHERENCE TO A WORLD VIEW THAT
MORE UNPOPULAR AROUND THE WORLD
AS THE DAYS, WEEKS AND MONTHS GO
ON.
I SAY THIS, VERY FEW OF THEM
HAVE THE PROFESSIONALISM TO STEP
BACK FOR JUST A MINUTE AND
ABSORB THE POSITIVE NEWS THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY HAS CREATED FOR
HEADLINE, LIKE, WHY AREN'T MORE
SOARING CONSUMER CONFIDENCE, THE
GOOD NEWS FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LATINO AMERICANS?
BECAUSE IT'S AGAINST THEIR WORLD
VIEW.
IMAGINE IF THE OPPOSITE HAD
IF TRUMP HAD PRESIDED OVER AN
WORLD.
STATEMENT PUNDITS WOULD HAVE
POUNCED ON HIS CONSERVATIVE
POPULISM AND BLAMED TRUMP FOR
THE DERAILMENT OF THE OBAMA
NO WONDER THE MEDIA'S APPROVAL
AND RATINGS KEEP FALLING.
I'LL TELL YOU THIS, THE MEDIA
AREN'T THE ONLY RABID FANATICS
TRUMP AND HIS AGENDA HAVE
EXPOSED.
JUST LOOK AT THE REACTION OVER
THE PAST 24 HOURS TO THE
PRESIDENT'S IMMIGRATION REFORM
AND DACA PLAN.
NOW LAST WEEK, REMEMBER, HE WAS
THE DEMOCRATS REJECTED THAT DEAL
AND SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
SO THIS WEEK, AFTER WORK A BROAD
WORK OF SENATORS, THE PRESIDENT
HAS LIVENED THE AMNESTY POOL TO
1.8 MILLION IMMIGRANTS.
PRESIDENT'S BASTE QUITE A BIT.
>> IF TRUMP GOES THROUGH WITH
THIS HE CAN LOSE MY VOTE IN
2020.
>> IF HE DOES THAT HE'S
COMMITTING POLITICAL SUICIDE.
>> NOT ONLY WILL HE DEMORALIZE
HIS BASE, HE'LL KILL THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IF HE CONTINUES TO PURSUE THIS,
HE'S CLEARLY LOST ME AS A VOTER.
I DON'T SEE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN HIM AND OBAMA.
>> I DID NOT GO FOR TRUMP FOR
HIM TO DO THIS AND I WILL NOT
VOTE FOR HIM AGAIN IF HE DOES
THAT.
THAT MONTAGE WE PUT TOGETHER.
FASCINATING.
EVERYONE KNOWS THIS IS NOT THE
THE SENATE SHOULD AGREE TO.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THE
PRESIDENT IS TAKING THIS RISKY
GAMUT IN A WAY TO GET COMMON
SENSE IMMIGRATION CONTROLS IN
PLACE.
WHAT HE'S THINKING, I BELIEVE,
IS THAT WE HAVE TO END THIS
MASSIVE INFLUX OF IMMIGRANTS
INTO THE UNITED STATES WHO ARE
ADMITTED WITHOUT REGARD FOR NEED
OR MERIT, WHAT THEY'LL BRING TO
THE COUNTRY.
AND WE ALSO MUST STOP THE WAVE
OF HUMANITY, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
BUSTING ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
PROCESS.
WE'LL SEE HOW IT WORKS OUT.
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE THE
VOTE IN THE CENTER FOR THE BILL,
WHICH I BELIEVE IS MUCH BETTER,
IT'S RIDICULOUS THE SENATE'S NOT
EMBRACING THAT.
THE PRESIDENT MOVED TO THE
MIDDLE.
NOT WHERE I'D BE BUT THAT'S
WHERE HE'S AT.
WHEN HE DID THAT HE ENRAGED HIS
SUPPORTERS AND PERHAPS RISKED
HIS OWN RE-ELECTION.
>> LET THE JUST SAY WHAT I SAID
LAST NIGHT, THAT PLAN IS A
CAMPAIGN TO MAKE AMERICA WHITE
WORK.
>> Laura: I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
THAT COMMENT MEANT BUT THESE
PEOPLE ARE TOTAL FANATIC.
THEY'RE FANATICAL FOR OPEN
BORDERS AND ENDLESS MIGRATION OF
LOW-SKILL LABOR FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSE AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN TOLD
YOU WHAT CHUCK SCHUMER SAID YET.
AS WE SAID EARLIER THIS WEEK,
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THEY HAVE TO
ELE
ELECTORATE AND NANCY AND SCHUMER
ETCETERA, HAVE TO KEEP THEIR
GRIEVANCE SOCIETY GOING AND
THE ECONOMY'S THRIVING.
THEY'RE OUT OF IDEAS.
ALL THEY BELIEVE IN IS DIVISION,
IDENTITY POLITICS, THE BLAME
GAME AND CALLING TRUMP A
DICTATOR.
THAT'S ALL THEY HAVE.
AND IF THE IMMIGRATION VIEW THEY
HAVE -- IF IT MEANS LOWERING THE
STANDARD OF LIVING FOR THE
AVERAGE WORKING PERSON, CITIZEN,
BY ADDING IN LOW-SKILLED
RESISTING -- IF IT MEANS
RESISTING TRUMP WHEN IT BENEFITS
VOTERS, SO BE IT.
I'M TELLING YOU, THESE PEOPLE
ARE DANGEROUS FANATICS AND IT IS
FORCES IN THE BODY OF POLITICS.